if you want to hear my theory about how
Elly created from pet sematary as well
as two other characters in that story
have the same ability as Danny Torrance
from The Shining then stick around to
the end of this video Stephen King's
third full-length novel The Shining is
titled after an ability held by a few of
the characters the mana introduce us to
the ability says that he and his
grandmother used to call it - the shine
it can be described as a psychic and
clairvoyant power whose intensity varies
from individual to individual dik
Halloran is the name of the head chef at
the Overlook Hotel who teaches Danny
everything he knows about the shine he
explains that he and his grandmother
used to have entire conversations
without ever opening their mouths but
it's not
Halloran explains that there aren't a
lot of people who shine but he's run
across maybe 50 or 60 who have a little
bit of shine to them so what is shining
actually consist of and why do I think
that Ellie from Pet Sematary has the
shine as dick mentioned those who shine
are capable of telepathic communication
danny is also able to hear the thoughts
of those who don't shine like how he
hears mrs. Brandt thoughts about the
hotel's valet Mike no I'm not gonna say
what those thoughts consisted of but
when Halloran asked Danny if he listens
to his parents thoughts he says that he
tries not to invade their privacy but he
can't help picking up on their feelings
or emotions there is evidence of Elliot
reading her father's mind or at the very
least picking up on his feelings in Pet
Sematary the family goes to visit
Ellie's Grandma and Grandpa on her
mother's side but Lewis doesn't go with
Louis strongly dislikes his
father-in-law because he tried to bribe
Lewis out of marrying Rachel making him
quite possibly the champion of
stereotypical in-law characters in
fiction Ellie somehow seems to know the
real reason and asked her father if he's
pissed off at grandpa to which Lewis
wonders how she possibly could have
known that Halloran also warns Danny
about some bad dreams that he's had at
the Overlook he tells him people who
shine can sometimes see things that are
gonna happen and I think they can
sometimes see things that did happen
when Ellie is away at her grandparents
house she has a dream of her cat Church
dying the night that Church is run over
by a truck and buried in the mcmac very
older
he got hit by a car and you and mr.
Crandall buried him in the pet cemetery
that was a silly dream but it wasn't too
silly of a dream and Ellie continues to
have dreams about past and future events
but if you don't want to get the ending
of Pet Sematary spoiled for you I would
not watch any more of this video why
don't you check out this one instead
those of you who have read the book may
remember that Ellie's next dream
involves Lois being dead a prediction of
the end of Pet Sematary and when Ellie
and Rachel are about to leave on the
plane Ellie begs her father to let them
stay or for him to come with and I think
this is because she senses her father's
life will be in danger
she also expresses more of her fears to
Louis at the airport
daddy I dreamed that we were at gages
funeral and the funeral man opened his
coffin and it was empty
then I dreamed I was home and I looked
at gages crib and that was empty too but
there was dirt in it this is just before
Lewis goes to dig up gage and try to
revive him in the mcmac burial ground
the first dream represents the fact that
Lewis will empty gages coffin in the
Pleasant View Cemetery and the second
one is a reminder of when the ghost of
Victor Paz cow tried to warn Louis in
the night not to go to the cursed burial
ground and Lewis wakes up with the dirt
of the pet cemetery path on his feet in
bed the next morning just before
boarding the plane Ellie begs one last
time listen to this portion Ellie gazed
at him solemnly with her Sybil's I I
don't want to go she said again but so
low that only Louis could really hear
over the shuffle and murmur of the
boarding passengers
I don't want mommy to go either Ellie
come on Louis said you'll be fine
I'll be fine she said but what about you
daddy what about you I find it very
interesting that King describes Ellie's
gaze as having come through Sybil's eyes
a word derived from the Greek word
Cibola which described a woman who
utters the Oracles and prophesies of a
guy shortly after Ellie has another
vision on the plane where she describes
gage coming alive again and wielding a
knife what happens next is interesting
if you think about another aspect of the
shine that dick Halloran describes to
Danny
he asks Danny to contact him if there's
any trouble at the Overlook that he
might even hear his call all the way
down in Florida
Danny later does use this to call for
help sending Halloran on his way to try
to rescue the Torrance family personally
I probably would have just left a little
guy I mean it's so much colder in
Colorado than it is in Florida why would
you leave something similar happens in
cemetary however instead of the child
calling out for help it is the ghost of
Victor Pascal who contacts Ellie in her
dream and takes her to the pet cemetery
in an attempt to try to get her to tell
Rachel what she had seen it's possible
that this isn't an example of a
long-distance call using the shining
though because maybe Pascal was just
able to travel anywhere because he's a
ghost this does send Rachel on her way
to try to put a stop to Luis his actions
however it seems unlikely she would
randomly take the word of a six-year-old
based on a bad dream that she had this
is why i think rachel has a little bit
of shine to her as well
in fact Halloran did mention that he
thinks all mothers shine a little at
least until her kids grow up enough to
watch out for themselves
this would also explain why Paz guy was
able to help Rachel throughout the
latter part of the story but there's one
more character that I think has a tiny
bit of shine as well when Rachel's on
her way home from Chicago she phones
dread Crandall to see if he knows why
Luis isn't home when speaking to her he
mentions that she sounds closer although
she did sound closer somehow he hears
the sound of the wind on a line and it
reminds him of the sound of dead voices
singing in chorus
I don't think Jud or Rachel realize that
they have the shine but if he does have
some faint sign of it it would explain
how he senses that Luis was getting
ideas about burying gage in the mcmac
grounds there is one more major aspect
of the shine though that leads me to
believe that Ellie has a pretty strong
case of it when Halloran is trying to
gauge how strong Dani shine is he asked
him to blast a thought as hard as he can
danny is much more powerful than
anticipated though
Halloran flies back in his seat and he's
injured by the force of Danny shine
which he compares to a Nolan Ryan
fastball well Ellie may be channeling a
little bit of Fergie Jenkins herself
because after Rachel leaves to go back
to Ludlow her father phones Louis about
a dream Ali had that is so powerful that
they end up taking her to the hospital
let me know in the comments if I can
come up with any other Stephen King
characters who have the shine and watch
this video if you want to hear some of
the things that you might have missed in
Stephen King's it remember to subscribe
to seize these worlds for new Horrors
every week ring that death bell for
notifications and I'll see you in the
next one assuming we both survive